my name is abdullah khabani i own a
phone repair company i'm going to walk
you through how to restore a cracked
ipad this is a 5th generation apple ipad
the person that brought this in if i
remember correctly one day he just
looked at it and he was really angry and
he just threw it against the garage wall
and that's how this happened since this
frame is bent like a banana it crushed
just about everything in its way
including the screen the battery and the
lcd to replace the frame we practically
have to rebuild the entire ipad reusing
all the parts that we can and replacing
the ones that we need to
[Music]
this screen is destroyed so we're just
going to yank it out
to get started we have to loosen up the
adhesive that's holding the screen down
into the frame normally we use some heat
with a heat pad but this frame was so
bent that it wouldn't sit down flat so
we have to use a heat gun
as i heat up and loosen up the adhesive
i'll use my blade to pry the glass up
from the frame
[Music]
i'll carefully scrape out the remaining
glass in the frame because that'll get
in the way when i try to remove this lcd
i'll remove the remaining glass with a
scalpel
[Music]
as soon as i lift up the lcd and expose
the battery connection i'll use this
little battery separator to remove any
power supply and the risk of shorting
something out
frame replacements require a whole lot
of work because i have to remove every
single component in this ipad and put it
into the new frame
every component is important and serves
a purpose so i have to be really careful
not to damage anything because we're
going to reuse it
the most important part is the
motherboard
my customer got really lucky that the
motherboard didn't get damaged with the
bend in the frame
in my experience all lithium batteries
have about a two and a half to three
year lifespan before they start acting
up and this ipad has been sitting in a
really cold garage for a long time so
since we're doing all this work we
figured we might as well replace the
battery so that it'll last a lot longer
i don't like using too much heat on the
battery so i'll use a little bit of
acetone to loosen up the adhesive then
jump straight to my spudger and pry that
thing out
i don't actually have to remove the
battery for this repair but it'll make
getting everything else out a lot easier
in order to safely do this repair i have
to be meticulous with my hand movements
because any slip
can damage a cable or a battery start a
fire
to get started with the reassembly we'll
install the power and volume buttons
just before installing the motherboard
i'm using my screwdriver and some screws
to hold it in place
some components require screws and
others just adhesive
we use a higher than original quality
aftermarket battery that uses texas
instruments capacitors that regulate the
power voltage
i use my tweezers my screwdriver and my
battery separating tool because even
though i'm putting the battery back in i
still don't want it to give any power to
the motherboard until i have everything
else plugged in
[Music]
i'll use some heat to loosen up the
adhesive underneath the home button
we'll have to transfer that one over to
the new screen
otherwise the fingerprint functionality
won't work anymore
[Music]
broken glass jars often get stuck to the
adhesive underneath the home button so i
have to be really careful because those
can damage the new screen
[Music]
to read here the home button we'll use a
mixture of slow and fast setting
industrial glue
i use four different types of glue to
seal the screen down onto the frame
i'll start by prepping the frame with
some adhesion promoter
i'll also use some industrial strength
glue
and a few drops of super glue so that it
sets fast just before we clamp it
[Music]
when i'm reassembling an ipad
even the tiniest speck of dust can ruin
the entire repair
a fingerprint could get in between the
layers of the screen and drive someone
insane and if it's already sealed up
then we'd have to open it up and do
about an hour of cleaning so we have to
be very careful
i used the clamps to secure everything
together
so i can restore the original airtight
seal
normally i would have to leave them on
for days but thankfully since i used a
few drops of super glue i only have to
leave it in for 20 minutes
[Music]
this specific repair took a lot more
work than your average ipad repair and
i'm just grateful that we were able to
bring it back to life
[Music]